We have completed the entirety of the
book of fasting
from
the book of Al Wajiz, which
which
by the way is not a small feat. That
actually contains a lot of knowledge, a
lot of information, a lot of
evidences and texts from both the Quran
and from the narrations of our prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam.
Invaluable knowledge condensed,
compressed, and
made accessible
thanks
to Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
followed by thanks to our scholars of
Islam.
Now, the author goes into the book of
al-i'tikaf.
The book of al-i'tikaf.
Al-i'tikaf in the Arabic language is
taken from the root word or the root
three-letter verb akefa.
Akefa, which is a past tense verb. And
akefa means
to for something to remain
at a at a particular place.
Right?
But it also in the Arabic language
it also usually has
a connotation of
devoutness or religiosity
to it.
You say akefa fulanun
it's almost as if you are saying he
religiously
remained at a particular place or at
a particular site.
And usually this word
has religious or worship
connotations to it, but not always.
But in general, the essence of this word
akefa
is to remain
at a particular place
or to remain at a particular site or to
remain around a particular thing.
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala uses this word
in the Quran. He mentions the people
He mentions
the people of
idols, the idol idolaters in the time of
Musa Alayhis Salaam that Musa and
Banu Israel came across after Allah had
delivered them across the Red Sea.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala relates this
story telling us that
in Surat al-A'raf and
upon delivering or after delivering
Musa and Banu Israel from their enemies
and across the sea, Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
mentions that in their path, they
encountered a group of people
that were
you know, camped out, if you will,
around some idols that they had.
And Allah uses these words ya'kufuna
'ala asnam lahum.
Ya'kufuna meaning that they were
they had these
idols. It was not necessarily a place
that they lived, but they were all very
clearly
staying here
around these idols in an act of devotion
and worship.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala also uses this
word with respect to its legislative
meaning al-ma'na shar'i in Surat
al-Baqarah. He says
So, in this near in this verse, Surat
al-Baqarah, Allah prohibits
sexual intercourse whilst a person is in
a state of I'tikaf in the masjid. And so
al-ukuf is to remain at something and to
be steadfast in your remnants around
this thing. And it usually has religious
connotations. Now, we will get into
exactly what an I'tikaf means
with the author's words here. He says,
"Al-I'tikaf
Al-I'tikaf
[Silence]
The author says, "An al-I'tikaf in the
last 10 nights of Ramadan is considered
to be a Sunnah of the Prophet Sallallahu
alayhi wasallam, which is highly
encouraged.
And the purpose behind I'tikaf being in
the last 10 nights of Ramadan
is that a person in his I'tikaf is
seeking out the night of al-Qadr. That
the night of al-Qadr be spent in the
masjid in the worship of Allah Subhana
[Arabic recitation]
He says,
"As Allah most high has said." And then
he mentions the entirety of Surat
al-Qadr, which translates to, "Indeed,
we have sent it, the Quran, down in the
night of al-Qadr.
And what could make you understand or
fathom just how significant and the
gravity of Laylat al-Qadr, the night of
al-Qadr.
The night of al-Qadr is superior in its
virtue than 1,000 months.
In Laylatul Qadr, the angels are in
constant descent by the will of their
Lord along with ar-Ruh, meaning Jibreel,
and also meaning
the
spirits
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's
worship and the embodiment of his
worship subhanahu wa ta'ala.
by the will of their Lord, and they
are descending
to
rectify and execute all affairs.
All affairs.
and this is why it is called Laylatul
Qadr. Allah says, "And it is a night of
great peace and a night of great virtue
until break of dawn." Now, this is where
Laylatul Qadr gets its name.
He says,
"Laylatul Qadr." The night of al-Qadr.
What's that mean? Often times it's
translated as the night of power.
This is quite a deficient
translation. Al-Qadr here, in the
correct opinion, is a reference to
decree,
destiny.
And that is that destinies are
written and
put into motion on Laylatul Qadr.
And being that there is great
amounts of du'a and supplication,
those destinies, for every one of us,
every one of us, every animal, every
creature, every human,
the wind, the rainfall, everything
that has to do with our
existence here on this earth, those
destinies are put into motion on Laylat
al-Qadr, which is why dua and
supplication and worship is so important
and so paramount during that time.
[Silence]
He mentions an narration on the
authority of Aisha who said that the
messenger of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
alayhi wasallam would spend his days and
nights camped in the masjid during
the last 10 days and nights of Ramadan.
And he would say meaning often he would
remind the companions radi Allah anhu
seek out the night of al-Qadr, the night
of destiny in the last 10 nights of
Ramadan. This narration has been
collected by al-Bukhari.
And also on the authority of Aisha
she narrates that the messenger of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala alayhi wasallam said
seek out Laylat al-Qadr
and seek
you know, the worship of the night of
Laylat al-Qadr in the odd nights of the
last 10 nights of Ramadan.
What does that mean in the odd nights?
In the odd nights. Is it not possible to
make I'tikaf only on the odd nights
of Laylat al-Qadr in Ramadan?
Meaning that the Prophet Sallallahu
alayhi wasallam would go into I'tikaf
for the 21st night and then go home for
the 22nd and then go in on the 23rd and
then go home for the 24th and then come
in at the 25th. Isn't that possible?
Where was his home with respect to the
masjid?
It was
almost inside of the masjid.
I mean, his door opened into the masjid.
All of the
all of his homes, all of his buyut
for his wives.
So, why didn't he do that? I- I- If we
are certain that the I'tikaf is for the
purpose of Laylat al-Qadr and that it is
only on the odd nights, then why didn't
he do that? Well, the answer lies in the
statement and witr.
The
odd nights. What does that mean? The odd
odd. Meaning that one extra
that comes on top of the even number.
Right?
Now, odd night
is odd with respect to what is past
or it is odd with respect to what is
remaining. Correct?
So, if we were to say the 21st night is
an odd night, that is an odd night with
respect to what is past.
With respect to what is remaining, it is
an even night.
Correct?
The 22nd night
is an even night with respect to what is
past of Ramadan. If we're counting from
one,
22nd is an even night.
But with respect to what remains,
meaning if we are counting down,
then the 22nd night is what?
Is an odd night.
And so, for this reason, the Prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam didn't reveal
Laylatul Qadr.
And it's not on any particular odd night
necessarily
odd with respect to what is past.
It is on an odd night
with respect to what is past or with
respect to what is remains.
If
Ramadan
is 30 days long,
then Laylatul Qadr
will be on an odd night with respect to
what remains of the month.
And if Laylatul Qadr is 29 days long,
then Laylatul Qadr will If and if
Ramadan is is 29 days long,
then Laylatul Qadr will be on an odd
night with respect to what is
past.
All right?
Now, here's the thing.
How do we know if a month is the month
of Ramadan is going to be 30 or 29 days?
Do we really know that?
I mean, we have our fancy calculations
now.
Don't we know everything?
Right?
As if
as if in the time of the Prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam calculation
didn't exist.
It did exist. It was arguably better
than it is today.
However,
the issue is that
The prophet
Muhammad was selling didn't tie it to
calculation. He tied it to what?
Sighting.
Yeah, the indicator. It is as if Allah
is saying, "Start Ramadan now. End
Ramadan now." By what? By showing us the
moon.
And so, we cannot know if the month is
going to be 29 or 30 days. Not with any
level of certainty.
However,
that is the point of spending the last
10 nights in the message.
if we knew exactly which night it would
be, we would make it give that night.
Right? Or we would make
we would make everything on that exact
night.
However,
it is not something that
is known to us. It moves around. And
therefore, we spend
extra amount of effort on every one of
the nights instead of all of our efforts
on one night.
Because it could be on odd night with
respect to what is past or it could be
on an odd night with respect to what
remains.
And we don't know that until the
month is over. And if you look at the
evidences, the cues of Laylat al-Qadr,
Does anyone here know some of the
evidences that Laylat al-Qadr, the
indicators?
An indicator of Laylat al-Qadr from the
Sunnah.
Hm?
It's about the star or about the sky the
following day or something that.
Hm, a little vague. Anybody have
anything more specific? The sun will
look the full
moon. No rays.
Right. So, I think that's what you're
trying to say. The sun comes up a little
bit dimmer than usual. You can see it as
more of a disc and not as a kind of
beaming light, right? You will be able
to observe the sun as more of a dimmed
light
than it is with the rays. All right? Any
anything else?
The rain.
That is not a general night a general
sign of Laylat al-Qadr.
that's a narration in Sahih Muslim
that the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam told the companions tonight is
Laylat al-Qadr and it happened to be
raining.
But, that's not something that happens
every single Laylat al-Qadr.
For instance, it is very calm. There's
very little wind. There's very little
activity, right? With with respect to
the weather.
Another indicator that some of the
scholars mention is
roosters crowing, a lack of barking
dogs. These are things that But, if if
we were to
gather all the
indicators of Laylat al-Qadr, you'll
find most of them
only show themselves after Laylat
al-Qadr is al-already done.
the sun, for instance.
How am I going to see that before Laylat
al-Qadr? I see that after.
Right? The narration is in Jami'
al-Tirmidhi. I see that the morning
after. So, what was the point of that?
Well, the point of that
is for a person to either
kick himself for missing it or to
you know be happy that they may have
spent their night in worship. The point
is we don't know when Laylat al-Qadr is.
And if it was fixed and it was the same
night every single year, the prophet
would have eventually told us which
night it is.
But we will continue this in sha Allah
tomorrow. Nas'al Allah subhanahu wa
[Arabic recitation]